كسرتها وتاج جدران الخوف في ايران باتمنطق
العيش بكرامه او الموت بشرف والشعار وكل
ما يتوغل هذا المنطق لشريحه ايرانيه اكبر
وتتزايد العقوبات الغربيه تلجا السلطات
لصناعه الخوف وزياده القمع نتيجه اصرارا
شعبيه اكبر على اسقاط النظام تعود على
اخماد المشاكل وليس حلها ولنا في الانترنت
دليل جديد الوسيله الوحيده لفتح ممارسات
السلطات والجيل زد شجاع بما يكفي صوته وصل
الى العالم عبر بوابه مواقع التواصل بدا
مما حدثنا
فالحب وباتواجبا وزيرو الداخليه الايراني
يريد حجما كاملا ويتهم الاعداء بصنع برامج
لرفع الحجم لكن الشعب هو من يقوم بذلك
وسنتطرق للامر بعد قليل
ما نتيجه هذه القيود هلا توقف الايرانيون
على الاحتجاج هل هناك فائده من الحجم
الاضرار كبيره على الاقتصاد الخسائر بالف
المليارات 11 مليون ايراني يتقاضون دخلهم
من تطبيق انستغرام فقط خسائر كل ساعه من
قطع الانترنت تعادل 45 مليار تومان
والعهده على صحيفه سترى صبح هذه هي
الخسائر تحديدا تنقلنا الى نقطه في نفس
الاتجاه الاحتجاجات وخرجت اصلا بسبب مقتل
سامينيني لكنها باتت الاطول منذ
1979 لاسباب اضافيه جوهريه بالطبع الاوضاع
والمعيشيه صعبه الاقتصاد المتدهور العمله
المتساويه سعر صرفها مقابل الدولار ارتفع
الى اكثر من
380,000 ريال رقم قياسي والسبب وراءه بين
نظر طعم هو المحتاجون ظاهريا يبدو الامر
صحيحا الاحتجاجات شلت القطاعات لكن
النظامه هو المسؤول عن اجراءاته خسائر
وحجم الانترنت اكبر مثال كما ان العمله
هوت بسبب عقوبات دوليه جديده فرضت بسبب
قمع الاحتجاجات اصلا وهكذا توضح بلومبرج
طبعا اذا انتقلنا للحرب الاوكرانيه سنجد
سببا اه اخر دعم روسيا بالمسيرات عقوبات
اخرى على ايران مزيدا من تدهور الاقتصاد
شهر مارس الماضي يضحك ايضا فرضيه النظام
سعره العمله الايرانيه انخفض وقتها مقابل
العملات الاجنبيه باكثر من 40% وانتشرت
منذ ذلك الحين الظاهره المواد الغذائيه
بالاثاث المنزلي والمقتنيات الشخصيه وذلك
في بلد يحتل المرتبه الثالثه عالميا من
حيث اعلى معدل تضخم حقيقي المواد الغذائيه
في الاشهر الثمانيه الاولى من 2022 اي قبل
الاحتجاجات
84 في المئه هذه ارقام البنك الدولي
وتركيبه ازمات مع احتجاجات لا يخمد
لانيرانها العنف قد تمثل وصفه حرب اهليه
وقتال داخلي وهنا التحليل لمؤسسه مؤسسه
ايسي الايدي المتخصصه بالابحاث ومقرها
ولايه وستانسن الامريكيه
[موسيقى]